hey guys chris kohler with wired com
here at the scene of the crime
nintendo's press conference where they
have a very special message for hardcore
gamers we don't want you anymore yeah we
heard a lot about a new wii sports we
heard a lot about animal crossing was
the closest thing to a bread-and-butter
game for mainstream gamers and that's
that's always been sort of you know a
game that some mainstream hardcore
gamers love but it is also been you know
so the outreach of new fans yeah this
this year's e3 press conference for
Nintendo Chris Baker was very casual
focused we saw a new animal crossing for
the we we saw we music for the week
which is very interesting sort of how
would you describe we music it's hard to
say it it could be like boogie or it
could be like a more family-friendly
kind of guitar hero thing it's hard to
say that you certainly look ridiculous
while you're playing it basically the
idea behind wii music is that it you
can't screw up basically you take the
wiimote you can use it to play over 50
different instruments on Nintendo's lead
designer Shigeru Miyamoto showed how we
can play the piano or or use it to play
guitar but whatever pretty much whatever
buttons you press how the song comes out
correct I mean that seems to be the idea
new yeah am so worried that it could be
like bogie which was impossible to fail
at yeah well we'll see how we music goes
that's going to be released alongside
the new animal crossing which has online
features this time around this holiday
but if you're a hardcore gamer not a
whole lot for you at a nintendo's press
conference in fact Nintendo's worldwide
president Satoru Iwata stood up and said
that Ivy Mario team and the Zelda team
are both hard at work on new entries in
the series but then didn't actually show
those new entries in the series season 5
yeah we've the closest thing to a big
new hardcore game were they even
admitted some of the modes in this
week's sports resort were very very fam
friendly very simple some of them may be
a little more hardcore arguably but
that's not until next spring right and
let's talk about wii sports resort it's
going to come with a nintendo's new
motion plus controller for the wii which
plugs into the Wii Remote and gives you
full 121 motion if you move the Wii
Remote around like a sword the on-screen
sword does everything that your hand
does and that's really key to these new
games in wii sports resort which is
going to come packaged with one of these
things they showed off a jet ski game
they showed us the frisbee game or
you're throwing a frisbee to a dog what
else they shut off a fencing game both
the sort of a mode where you're just
slicing up lots of wood shopping pencils
and a mode where you're actually
squaring off against someone else and
hacking / walking yeah then you guys you
don't need a new zelda game for wii ok
you have pencil sharpening but you know
what you know it's again the exact same
sort of conference that we would have
expected from nintendo very casual
focused very much touting the fact that
they are you know the number one and two
platforms right now with games on the
Nintendo DS they actually showed well
didn't show but announced up at Grand
Theft Auto is actually coming to the
intend ODS later this year apparently
Grand Theft Auto called chinatown Wars
arrives on d s this winter we also we
heard a line not too subtle jab at
Microsoft that other people are sort of
picking up on their innovations they
didn't really dig the knife in and twist
it though they just said it sort of they
need to disrupt themselves and come up
with new things even if it is
revolutionary sooner or later people
will become tired of a new form of
entertainment this happens pasta when
others try to reproduce the initial
change the hill also announced the
nintendo DS players are now 50 50 men
and women in their own introducing a lot
more games for women on the nintendo
ds's cooking nabi which is game in South
Japan it's actually a virtual cookbook
that works with the BS is it could you
even really call it a game I mean are
there game like elements or is it just
kind of a
if cookbook no absolutely would not call
it a game and it's an interactive
cookbook that you actually put in your
kitchen and use it to help you cook
recipes well in closing Chris Baker I'd
have to say Nintendo obviously
introducing a lot of really interesting
new products for that casual that
expanded audience it's buying so many
ways so many ds's but at the same time
kind of abandoning even further that
hardcore base that supported them all
these years I'm hurt is it me is it
something I said I